hey everybody welcome back to townscaper
a few days ago a new update for the game
was released which added a bunch of
tricks to its arsenal and i think
they're very well worth showing off in
this video
and in fact i'm just gonna have a bunch
of time lapses throughout this video to
show off a couple of different things
but i'm starting off with this which i
think is the most interesting new
addition
as you might be able to tell the grid
has kind of changed and you get these
areas with perfect round circles
and sort of symmetrical shapes and if
you build
something in the sky on one of these
shapes you actually get a floating
island and you get these little
propellers at the bottom of it to keep
the whole thing in the air
which is super cool and that's just the
first thing i wanted to try out because
it's
it i mean i guess it just adds this this
whole other game mode to it where you're
building a real floating island
instead of just a little island in the
ocean and
as much as i already said in the first
video that i made about this game that
it reminds me of the art style of ghibli
movies
this just reminds me instantly of lapita
castle in the sky
and it's so cool i really love how you
can just build completely different
islands this way
you do have to build them on these
symmetrical shapes as soon as you get
different corners they start building
supports back to the ground which
i guess it makes sense because you don't
really get the option to build flying or
on the ground so you really have to
build in some specific places on the
grid
but once you do get there there's so
much cool stuff that you can do with
this
and i've seen many really cool creations
of people just stacking different
floating islands of different shapes and
sizes and of course as always you can
move around the grid to find a spot that
you like and see what you can do with
that shape
one of the most recognizable shapes i
think
is you'll find these stretches on the
grid where you have a perfect line
of just a complete square grid and along
this line you'll usually find
some spaces that kind of look like a bar
of soap you'll you'll see a few squares
kind of in the shape of a bar of soap
and i'll actually get into that later in
this video but i think those are
the easiest shapes to find that you can
build floating islands on
but once you start moving around the
grid a little bit you'll start
recognizing these shapes and
it becomes a lot easier to build in the
sky and
successfully built these floating
castles so that's also what i'm doing
here
basically just throwing a disc in the
air and then building a sort of disney
inspired castle on top of it
not too much to it in terms of the the
kind of colors or variations of
buildings that i'm
putting down here it's mostly inspired
by the kind of concentric city model
which by the way that was my phone
ringing sorry about that we're
getting rid of that um but yeah it's
mostly inspired by these concentric
cities i know people like to do those in
city skylines a while ago
i think conflict nerd had some really
cool videos about that
but um yeah we're doing it on a very
small scale here one thing to keep in
mind is that these floating islands will
have to be
not just symmetrical but of course the
grids are also limited you don't find
infinitely huge circles on the on the
grid
so you can't build these things too big
and i would say that this island i'm
building here is actually one of the
bigger shapes i found
i don't know if there are bigger shapes
out there if you just keep searching
but this is what worked best for me and
yeah i'm keeping it pretty simple
otherwise just some
warm colors and kind of mediterranean
vibe that i'm going for here
i had some uh sort of platforms below
this island before but
i realized that you can only have the
little propellers
on one floor of a certain flying island
so you kind of have to choose there
either they would have to be separated
or i just had one floor and i ended up
opting for just one floor
and just leave it at that but then i
realized that there were actually some
pretty good
shapes next to this island as well and
here's where you find that kind of bar
of soap shape that i was talking about
earlier
if you look on the floor you get this
kind of round-ish rectangular shape and
well the way that flying islands work is
that you just have to find a shape where
you don't have any pieces that have an
edge
or that you know completely curve
outward so even though this shape looks
like it has some edges
you'll notice that every edge piece is
actually one of those small
round pieces where you can build a round
tower on it
so as long as you just have those grid
spaces on the outside of your island
you'll be able to
put it in the air and not have any
supports pop up
something to also keep in mind is that
as soon as you build out from this
and maybe you build a small peninsula
away from this flying island
if it's on the same floor it'll just
stop flying and if you're building above
it
you'll just create a peninsula with
supports that go all the way down to the
to the ground so that does kind of ruin
the
the whole appeal of this and then i
discovered that there was also another
space that i could build a flying island
on
this one actually has a really great uh
shape with
six edges which is honestly one of the
better shapes i've found for flying
islands at least
in my opinion and i i noticed it kind of
late i was just looking at the grid
thinking if there was any
possible place for another flying island
and there we go
so you always have to pick very
carefully where you want to build and
definitely if you're looking for
spots to build multiple flying islands
together
you do have to look for these kind of
places where you can notice
a bunch of symmetrical shapes close in
one space
especially because over here the kind of
symmetrical
grit layout is only very short you can
notice that
there's some symmetry radiating
radiating out from
each of these spaces but it very quickly
starts devolving into a messy random
grid again
and i say messy and random but there's
all kinds of complicated algorithms
behind that
no doubt but it's something that you
can't build flying islands on
so now that's all built let's take a
quick look at what it looks like in the
game
and then i've got some other stuff for
you guys
so here we are at the thumbnail of this
video and
there's something that i completely
forgot to talk about during the time
lapse but
you might have noticed that the lighting
in the game is a little bit different
and that's because we can completely
change it now so at the moment
it's kind of at golden hour which i have
to say is probably my favorite time of
day to play this game maybe i could
make it a little bit lighter but yeah it
looks really cool and i think
especially on builds like this it really
brings out the warm colors of
all of the buildings um but yeah we can
basically now change the time of day
and the position of the sun to whatever
we want to
and if we pull it down all of the way we
actually get some nighttime mode as well
and all of the lights turn on the
buildings which is super cool
so yeah i'm a really big fan of these
new lighting
changes and especially for taking
screenshots it's really nice because you
can basically just put your camera
somewhere and then
try and figure out what the best
position for the sun
is to just get just the right picture
but there are still some other things
that i want to show off so
let's get back into the quick time lapse
and build something else
so yeah i barely had enough time to talk
about this during the first time lapse
so let's just keep going and talk about
all of the other stuff that has been
added to the game
i already showed some of the lighting
effects but even when you're building
it's a pretty cool thing to add to your
build because building with a different
lighting just changes the whole game and
you have to think differently about
colors i suppose
so for this build i decided to just
build at night
and see how that goes i do think i just
prefer building at daytime or
maybe even golden hour because
especially
you know the use of different colors
that might not work very well together
it's difficult to prevent that at night
but at the same time i think all of the
colors in this game are very well chosen
and
can work together in any kind of
situation so it doesn't matter too much
but yeah for this island i wanted to try
something slightly different and not
build one of those concentric tall
disney boys so i'm just going for a
small town with the church in the middle
kind of standard kind of predictable um
but what you're not noticing is that
actually the whole time i'm playing this
i'm trying to
carefully select a color scheme with a
kind of blue tint a little bit of red
thrown into the mix as well but i'm
definitely leaving most of the uh the
colors in the game out
and then as soon as i switch to daytime
we'll see what it looks like because
right now at night you don't really
notice any of the colors
i am using red and the the lighter beige
colors to get a bit of contrast in in
terms of the buildings because you can
definitely see which buildings are light
and which buildings are dark
but the colors just kind of disappear so
for me at this time it's also completely
a surprise
to see at the end of the day what this
island is really going to look like
in daylight and um while i'm just
building a way i do want to mention some
of the other stuff that has changed in
the game because
really the the lighting and the flying
islands in different grid
aren't all of it you can also take
screenshots which
if you paid attention at the start of
this video and you could still see the
ui on the right side
you probably have noticed that there is
a screenshot button now
you can hold down undo and redo to very
quickly remove or
redo everything and apparently there
have also just been some bugs say
um bug fixes and stuff like this
so the game should all together work a
little bit better
one thing i did notice is that sometimes
the camera will be a little bit confused
with flying castles to
see exactly what heights it should focus
on
but that aside i haven't had any issues
with the game with the updates
anyway so that's pretty good and also
something that for some reason wasn't
included in the patch notes at least not
on the community page
on steam but is pretty noteworthy
is the fact that we also have two new
graphics options now if you look
at the yeah the little slider on the
right of the ui where you can change the
position
of the sun and the time of day below
that there's a
little circle it's gone now but there's
a little circle a square and a star-like
shape the circle
is the basic graphics of the game as
you're used to
the square is some kind of downgraded
graphics version where you don't have
the
shadows and dynamic lighting and then
the star is really interesting it
removes all of the textures in the game
so it makes every
building white and well every detail and
even the birds that fly around just
completely textureless
but you still have the lighting and the
shapes of your builds so
it sounds weird but those effects can
actually allow you to make really cool
pictures of your builds
and at least look at them in a different
light which i think is really cool
and a neat graphical addition to the
game as well
now to come back to this build i uh i i
built this flying island and then i
realized that there were two uh
bars of soap if you will next to the
island and i figured that i might as
well
build something out of that so i built
one of those islands
and then just decided to build another
one in a different color scheme
and yeah that's basically it for this
build
let's just hop into the game and see
what it looks like for a while i was
trying to build a bridge here but
i ended up removing that thing
connecting the islands is still
something that's a little bit more
tricky to figure out but
it's it's something you can do i suppose
but yeah let's just quickly take a look
at it
so this build is a little bit more flat
than the other one
at least in terms of the actual
buildings the colors are
i guess a bit more vibrant let me make
it kind of
a little bit more light there we go and
uh yeah basically we have the red island
and the green island and blue island
with some variations actually i guess i
should call this the yellow one because
it also has yellow which the others
don't have
but yeah some slight color variations
and i think even with these
kind of crazy and not always fitting
colors together
it still works and it still looks pretty
good and
i think it's also worth showing off the
grid space on the bottom here
because it's very easy to find this this
bar of soap if you will
i don't know who caught it a bar of soap
i found it somewhere but
yeah it's definitely that kind of shape
and you also notice that we have this
big stretch of well almost a straight
line here i don't know how much further
that continues but yeah there you go
it continues pretty far so if you go out
from there you can find
another bar of soap here and well
undoubtedly if the grid were to continue
here
you'd find more symmetrical shapes so
sometimes you just have to come across
this kind of axes
and you can find lots of usable shapes
around that as well
oh but look at that though at night it
just looks so cool
and i really love these little dioramas
that you get
anyway i'm gonna move on i'm still not
gonna let you guys go
because um i was addicted to playing
townscaper and just
trying out random stuff and i recorded
all of it anyway so i figured
it's gonna be a messy video but i might
as well throw everything into a video
and see what i can make of it
and this build i think was worth showing
off because
well in the last video i made venice and
i was really sad about how
saint mark's bell tower on the central
plaza
just looked not very convincing built on
a single grid space
so i figured it's a decently simple
building really um with colors that are
all in the game
so it should probably be possible to
recreate it in the game at least
somewhat believably and well looking at
the tower structure itself i guess
that's partly true because you can
definitely
build the uh the red section the lower
section of the tower and then
going into the the white part at the top
pretty
convincingly but i totally forgot that
there's no good
piece in the game for the roof so yeah
to be fair
i do think the roof ends up looking a
little bit derpy in the end
especially given the fact that it's just
some green walls and then
still the orange roof on top of that so
it's a kind of strange structure
but it's recognizable and i think
sometimes i have to scale down my
expectations a little bit and realize
that this game isn't meant for this kind
of stuff at all and
the fact that you can achieve this very
easily and very quickly without having
to
you know work at the game too much just
by doodling around
it's uh it's pretty cool and it's still
pretty fun to build
so i'm very happy with the final results
and let's just check it out for a second
so here's the end result it's not the
best thing i've ever made but it was
pretty fun to build
and i guess it's recognizable and i made
it very quickly so
i can't really be too disappointed i
guess this is a good case study for
the term well the the phrase yet the
trace of the true self exists in the
false self
because i guess that's true enough here
anyway let's move on there's one more
thing i want to show you guys
and no i'm still not letting you guys go
because there's one more thing
i want to showcase in the first video of
townscaper
i tried building some skyscrapers and
while i concluded that it's really not
meant for that kind of thing
and it usually even makes your game lag
a bit too much because those builds are
way bigger than the game is intended for
also you get these strange details in
the roofs and
planters and random clothes
hanging from wires between the buildings
all of that stuff
it's not really meant for this but at
the same time it's just too much fun
to build these things and i'm a big fan
of going against the game's intentions
so screw it let's just do it um and i
figured that
given the fact that we now have
perfectly round grids and also perfectly
square grids
as well which you can definitely find
especially if you look for those
lines of perfectly square grids that
just go across the map
you can now much better build
skyscrapers and
maybe just come up with a single
skyscraper design and see how that goes
it doesn't have to be too intricate
but it's uh something worth pointing out
so for this one for instance i was
trying to go something kind of patronus
towers inspired
except just one instead of twin towers
kind of post-modern with a big
well spire on top um
and yeah i think it kind of works and
also it's a good exercise of the
new graphic mode where you just
completely remove all of the textures
because it helps a little bit with
coming up with skyscrapers because you
don't have to deal with the weird colors
of the roofs anymore
or with the details like windows on the
walls um
so yeah all together i think it's still
a fun exercise to try and build
skyscrapers in the game and i know i'm
not the only person who has done this
i've seen
so many great skyscraper builds pop up
as well just figured
that everybody watching this should know
that this is a really fun thing that you
can do with the game as well and
especially now that we have the new grid
types
there are so many options for just
doodling about
with modernist architecture as well so
let's take a quick look at that
and then i promise the video is over
god i love that sound anyway here's our
rendered final building
uh before the windows are in when i
think it actually looks
a little bit better because as soon as
all of the windows start appearing
you notice that in reality this thing is
just a grotesquely
huge castle mess but um
now let's turn off the textures again
and see what that looks like i think for
kind of modern builds like this you can
actually play with the textureless
models
and especially see what kind of lighting
looks best on it because you can
definitely make things look pretty cool
as soon as you just get the
the right lighting so that's something
fun to play around with
and maybe you can even build some cities
from lord of the rings with this or
something like that
the last thing i want to show is that
you also have this sort of simplified
option i haven't seen many people make
use of it and
to be fair i'm actually not sure what to
call it i'm not an expert of these kinds
of things
but uh it's also there which is good to
note and you can make some
well simplified lighting-less versions
of your city with this as well
and i always find it fun to open up my
old saves
and just go through the new options and
see what they look like
actually let's just do that for the last
part of this video
i swear this video will never end on my
watch
anyway i hope you guys enjoyed this and
found it a good look into all of the new
stuff in townscaper
and if you have it or if you're still
looking to buy it
i highly recommend checking out all of
these new graphic options because
they're just really fun to play with
like anything in the game
there's not really that much of a point
to it but that's just the
the fun therapeutic doodling aspect
of it i suppose anyway i'll see you guys
in the next video of townscaper because
i
do imagine there are still some updates
to come so
whenever anything is getting added or i
get a weird random idea
i'm sure we'll find each other here
again bye guys